oh wait
um
how much can a single expression convey
Steven unit is one of my favorite actors
working right now and one of my favorite
performances from him is his restrained
ambiguous work as Ben in Lee Chong
dang's burning
[Music]
sushi
hostage I'm not going to spoil the
movies I talk about in this video but
here's some context for this one jiangsu
has randomly reconnected with a friend
from school hey me who he has an
unexpressed crush on meanwhile hey me
while she's off on a trip abroad becomes
friends with wealthy and mysterious Ben
who she's interested in it's classic
Love Triangle stuff but there's another
layer here there's this scene where they
all go to dinner with some of Ben's rich
friends and hey me at Ben's
encouragement is demonstrating a dance
she learned while she was traveling
jongsu is watching her and then looks
over at Ben and catches him yawning and
then Ben gives him this look
there's so much in this brief moment a
feeling that he doesn't really care a
kind of contempt that she's just a play
thing to him but there's also this
element of bringing jiangsu into that
feeling there's a you know sort of
aspect to the look that feels like it's
trying to make jiangsu complicit in
Ben's Behavior something that is found
only in Steven yeun's performance that
alludes to a whole world of subtext that
eventually becomes very important to the
film
this video is sponsored by
curiositystream sign up for the
Curiosity stream plus nebula bundle and
watch my full companion video for this
video about screen presence on nebula
you have nothing when people talk about
best performances in film a lot of stuff
comes up and a lot of it is this kind of
thing the big evocative roles the roles
that require the actor to transform
themselves into a character completely
in some way for the Oscars it's even
better if that transformation requires
some kind of challenging element like
weight loss prosthetic makeup or an
accent like so much of the rest of the
Oscars it can sometimes feel like the
awards go to most acting and not
necessarily best acting I think one of
the reasons The Joker has become such an
enduring screen character isn't
necessarily because he's just a more
compelling villain but because he's
become a character that is a playground
for bold expression that the regular
boundaries of performance may not allow
and actors enjoy lining up and taking
their swing at the role almost as much
as audiences enjoy watching those swings
and this video is not about how these
kinds of performances are bad I love and
I've abandoned my moment as much as
anybody in fact my favorite actor Tilda
Swinton while she definitely can play
subtle roles often doesn't one of the
reasons I love her work is in part
because she's willing to go way
overboard and transform herself into all
manner of absurd character for even
small supporting roles so I'm not here
to bash that kind of acting I think it's
great but in all the praise for this
kind of showy and transformational
acting I think some of the best
performances or moments of performance
can get overlooked so I want to showcase
an aspect of performance that I think is
less recognized but no less impressive
these moments are not ones where the
actors transform themselves but ones
where they seem to disappear into a
character where you can no longer see
the actor on screen performing and
instead just see their character feeling
the emotion of the drama
often what sets these kind of
performances apart is the subtlety with
which these actors can convey deep rich
and complex emotion with their faces and
their bodies they've embodied the
character to the point where they
communicate what they want to
communicate through the character not
just with line delivery but with even
the tiniest of Expressions sometimes
these subtler reactions and expressions
can play a very important role within
the story itself besides the Steven Yoon
character in burning Daniel kaluya and
get out is another great example of this
kaluya plays the big emotions in this
movie well but even more importantly his
reactions to the world around him gives
the film subtext a lot of weight and
helps guide the audience into the
absurdity of the experience such a
privilege to be able to experience
another person's culture like the way
this look right here telegraphs yeah I
know what you really mean the exact
subtext of a lot of Daniel caluya's
reactions in the first part of this
movie are just as important as any of
the lines the other characters are
saying another recent performance I
think is really great is Florence Pugh
and midsummar she Nails the big
outpouring of emotion necessary for
certain scenes but I think almost more
impressive is her command of a subtler
smaller moments the film opens with the
death of her family and look at this
moment where a friend brings it up also
I
I never had the chance to tell you but I
was
I was so very sorry to hear about your
loss
oh what happened I mean I the way her
expression sort of melts into a subtle
grief it's the kind of thing that looks
like it could only really be an
automatic reaction to a sudden memory or
realization there's a similar moment
from a bit part in The Darjeeling
Limited that always gets me the Three
Brothers show up at their father's
mechanic to pick up his car on the way
to his funeral and the way the mechanics
subtly responds to finding out the
father died you'll have to wait another
week I left a message yeah he didn't get
the message Mr Whitman is dead you
understand
foreign
yeah for some reason to me one of the
saddest things in the film continuing on
this theme of grief Rooney Mara conveys
it powerfully in David Lowry's a ghost
story sometimes grief can leave you
Frozen in shock and that seems like it
should be easy to pull off for an actor
you just don't move but there's
attention and involuntary element to
what looks like genuine shock that is
different from just not moving and here
there's the smallest involuntary twitch
that somehow sells this moment as more
authentic one of the reasons I think I'm
drawn to these kind of subtle moments is
that I think they often convey a kind of
complexity of emotion that isn't
necessarily there in bigger outbursts
pulling off the big outbursts in a way
that feels authentic is certainly a
challenge but what about the Nuance of
expressing repressed emotion what about
when you want the audience to perceive
that the character is feeling an emotion
and also perceive that the character is
trying to hold that emotion back Amy
Adams does it here in Spike Jones her in
this moment where her character wants to
cry but is also obviously trying not to
Charles and I split up
what yeah
really
or what about the complexity of multiple
emotions arising at once Oscar Isaac
Nails this in HBO's remake of scenes
from a marriage in this scene he and his
wife played by Jessica Chastain decide
to keep an accidental pregnancy ava'll
be thrilled
and your parents oh God yeah and this
little moment of expression
is amazing the amount of fear hope and
trepidatious joy that are all somehow
fighting to come out at once even while
he attempts to hold them back is
incredible to me I find this kind of
thing compelling because in my
experience I think this is what a lot of
real life emotion is actually like sure
there are the big yelling and punching
the wall moments for some people
sometimes but I think far more
frequently there's emotion that people
are trying to conceal or that is a
tangled mix of different emotions
instead of just one big one risimed has
this great moment in sound of metal
where he asks his mentor and sobriety
sponsor for money I was wondering Joe I
don't know if it's possible
foreign
just to buy back my RV
you know
me me and Lou is
all
and the way grief and shame seem to
Bubble to the surface while he fights it
back hits me every time watching this
people talk a lot about range in acting
as the ability to play different types
of characters but I think there's also a
kind of range in terms of intensity we
all know Joe Pesci for the Sinister
intensity that he has in Goodfellas
funny how I mean what's funny about it
oh Anthony
he's a big boy he knows what he said
what'd you say funny how this guy is
right on the edge you don't want to mess
with him he feels like he could snap at
any moment and he's genuinely terrifying
tell me tell me what's funny
so it's impressive to me that in the
Irishman his character is no less
Sinister and threatening
there's been a change
instead of uh
we're going up right away we're gonna
hang around tomorrow morning and then go
up drive up
nobody told Jimmy that we were gonna be
up in the morning
I told you if I told Jim we were going
to be up in the morning why no I know
even though the intensity of the
performance is dialed way back until it
almost disappears we got to go there I
mean I gotta go I got I told him I'd be
there
Frankie
we did all we could for the man
the fact that he can convey something so
similar through completely different
levels of intensity is why he's one of
the greats when I talk about these kinds
of subtle Expressions I think rarely are
they a very conscious Choice by the
actor I don't think Rooney Mara is
acting that scene thinking my neck is
going to Twitch and that's going to make
it feel more real rather this kind of
subtlety is the result of the actors
finding a way to actually experience or
feel the emotions they're trying to
convey and the subtle micro expressions
are the result of that but one of the
reasons I've never talked about acting
despite the fact that I've made over 100
videos about film and television now is
because the craft is kind of a mystery
to me when I listen to actors talking
about their craft there's not a
consistent approach that wins out and
seems to be the best and when actors
talk about how they accomplish these
kinds of performances it's often very
esoteric and it's all about arriving at
a point of authenticity and sometimes
completely differing techniques can get
you there sometimes they refine things
through extensive rehearsal and
sometimes actors find that in the
spontaneity of a first take it's kind of
impossible to reverse engineer a
performance just by looking at the
screen and trying to figure out what the
ACT did to get there and so I think
talking about technically what makes for
good acting is a pretty difficult feat
all I can really do is look at these
performances and assess how authentic or
unforced it feels to me I think a lot of
these techniques are just finding a way
to access genuine emotion and then this
very realistic expression comes out of
that that said if there are performers
out there who have this kind of
conscious control of my new micro
expressions in a way that feels
involuntary I mean that's almost more
impressive there are so many Fantastic
examples of this kind of performance out
there and this isn't meant to be a
definitive list or a list of the best
examples of this these are just specific
examples that have stuck with me because
they impacted me in a certain way and as
I was looking through all these examples
and trying to understand what quality it
is that allows this kind of subtle
expression to come through in these
performances I noticed that a lot of
these performances have a quality that I
would call screen presence I think
screen presence is an interesting idea
and it's one I wanted to explore a
little more thoroughly so I made a
companion video all about that that is
available exclusively on nebula putting
this video on nebula a streaming service
made for and by creators allows me to
explore this topic in depth with longer
examples without having to worry so much
about copyright claims if you don't have
nebula click the link in the description
below you can get it for an entire year
for less than fifteen dollars using the
Curiosity stream plus nebula bundle
there's so much great content on nebula
that you can't get anywhere else in
addition to the companion video here
about screen presence you can also find
Lindsay Ellis's nebula original about
how the Lord of the Rings films were
adapted I have a podcast that I do with
my fellow video essays Tom vanderlunden
from like stories of old called Cinema
of meaning and if you listen to that on
nebula you get episodes early and AD
free and you also get a bunch of bonus
exclusive episodes that are only for
nebula listeners check all of that out
and you can get access to my normal
YouTube content available ad free and
early on nebula nebula is great because
there's no advertising and no algorithms
which changes the incentives for the
Creator we can focus on making the best
content possible without having to focus
on what's going to get the most clicks
and I have a great deal for you if you
want to sign up curiosity stream another
service has partnered with us to create
a bundle curiositystream has their own
extensive library of great educational
documentary and non-fiction content and
when you sign up for curiositystream
using my link below you'll get curiosity
stream and nebula for free with
curiositystream for less than 15 a year
go sign up right now by clicking the
link on the screen or in the description
below go to curiositystream.com
thomasflight
[Music]
thank you